all right let's uh let's let's talk
about this this first story
and uh man
we live in truly the dumbest of times i
suppose the daily mail runs this story
why no one needs to work in biden's
america experts project anyone who
earned thirty two thousand dollars
before covet could now earn more in
benefits staying home the average weekly
unemployment benefit is now six hundred
thirty eight dollars three hundred
dollars more than what it was in 2019
that means people are earning around 16
an hour more than double minimum wage
which was at least 725 across america
not even that if you're living in new
york and you're getting 15 bucks an hour
working fast food you're like
might as well just quit
i'll get a raise yeah raise it don't
work so this is all this is this so they
say it's creating a nightmare scenario
for the economy businesses are desperate
to recover from the pandemic but they
can't fill their jobs the funny thing is
there are 7.1 open jobs i guess that's
like the number that comes from the
government
266 000 jobs created in april because
people are going in they're like how
much do you pay and they're like 15 an
hour and they're like me i'm going home
you said 7.1 million jobs
are open right now looking for people to
work and there's nobody wants to do it i
know i know at least five people who are
doing the unemployment thing knowingly
avoiding work because of it well
this is actually i don't blame them not
every single person so
when i was i think i was maybe 20 or 21
i got unemployment for losing a job and
the people at the unemployment office
literally told me
not to take a job that was paying less
because it creates a dependency so like
i was talking to them and they're like
look
look for work
we don't expect you to take a really low
paying job because the fear is that if
you can't support yourself you'll just
be right back here on the phone again so
find a real job it's like oh okay all
right that's they told me they were like
otherwise we just get too many people
who keep taking bad jobs and can't
sustain themselves what do you think's
happening now people are getting 16
bucks an hour they're like there's no
way i can take 15 bucks an hour because
i can't pay my bills right getting more
unemployment and i think it's actually a
bit worse than that because if you if
you actually think through the logic of
the economics of it right it's not just
that if you're getting paid sixteen
dollars an hour to do nothing that
doesn't just mean like oh okay well i'll
only take a job for seventeen dollars an
hour that means that a job at seventeen
dollars an hour is effectively a job at
one dollar and exactly that you have to
work for one dollar an hour a job at
twenty dollars an hour is four dollars
an hour plus you got to get up every day
plus you got to pay for gas or
transportation or this so now it comes
back down i mean you you it really
throws the incentives wildly off there's
good news here though because the uh
backdoor ubi experiment has proven it
doesn't work and so let's just get ubi
out of there sorry sorry ubi enthusiasts
i think joe joe is a ubi enthusiast yeah
well it's a question of who it doesn't
work for you know i mean it certainly
doesn't work for the taxpayer i suppose
it works for the people who are
collecting these benefits temporarily
but what does it actually do long term
you know if you can just imagine like
imagine if we were just on a desert
island somewhere and you were like okay
we're all poor we're on this desert
island we gotta work someone's gotta
pick fruit someone's gotta fish
someone's got to build shelter we got to
work and then someone else said well
i'll just uh i got paper in my pocket
i'll supervise and i'll just yeah i'll
supervise and i'll start divvying out
the paper amongst us and they go don't
worry you're really wealthy because i
gave you this money that's basically the
game that we're playing right now where
it's it's less and less people actually
producing anything well but we can
pretend we all have wealth because we're
passing around these paper federal
reserve notes well this actually is
extremely beneficial to
you know the great reset davos group
kind of people because think about it
right now
they have created a system in which
people will make more money not working
which means no consumption no plastic no
pollution no waste no gas being used no
carbon emissions just people sitting
around being like oh
and the best part is they're dragging
everyone else down with them so it's
like it's the ultimate crabs in a bucket
the only issue is the crabs you know
crabs in a bucket is crabs in a pro
right whenever a crab tries to get out
the other crab pulls it down that
implies that one crab is like hey you
can't leave or i'm gonna climb out of
you to escape in this instance it's
people just being tied to the other like
all the crabs are tied together so when
a bunch of crabs were like nah we're
better off in the bucket don't leave the
ones that actually want to do better are
being weighed down by those who don't
what's happening basically is
people got to understand this dollars
are meaningless
a dollar is just the current
representation of the value of the labor
you've traded
and it only really matters that day
because the value keeps changing because
it's a deflate you know it's an
inflationary currency it devalues itself
over a long period of time
so you go and work you get 10 bucks if
you sit on that money it becomes worth
less every single day the reason it is
because the government just prints and
borrows money so what's happening is you
create value with your labor let's call
it a unit of labor one hour you create
one hour
and then someone comes up to you and
says i'd like to trade you one hour of
my labor the only problem they didn't
actually have any real labor behind that
dollar because the government just
printed it and gave it to them so the
total amount of value in the system
stays the same but the total amount of
trade currency to to exchange value
keeps going up yes and if i could take
that a step further because you're
absolutely right if you were to
uh enslave somebody and take an hour of
their labor i enslave you for an hour
and i take you were a slave for that
hour that unit of your hour
was ill-gotten by me because i enslaved
you yeah but if you work for that hour
and you get one unit of federal reserve
notes and then i print that money away
and slowly and slowly steal it from you
what have i really in effect done other
than retroactively enslaved you for the
time that you were yes but you're still
happy
well for the for a little bit i don't
know this country this country doesn't
seem that happy to me
yeah but for stupid reasons
for for like the stupidest of reasons
they think nazis are running around
everywhere it's like have you gone
outside that's just not reality you know
in addition to what you guys are talking
about about the value of labor and the
federal reserve note representing that
not only are they printing more notes
and hoarding them so that the value of
the actual note to labor ratio is
devaluing but people aren't actually
doing labor that's my so there's even
less value that's what i just said and
and so
it's one thing like after world war ii
modern monetary policy printed a bunch
of extra money so that they could create
production to then pay off the debt that
they that they created right now we're
just printing the money without the
production creation but they're probably
doing it for the same reason so a lot of
people talked about how these blue
states had massive debt and then they're
like we better pump trillions of dollars
into the economy right and then shut
down all the small businesses so only
the massive multinational corporations
take all that money
well i'll tell you one of the huge
differences right okay so after world
war ii as we were talking about before
right there's every industrial country
in the world was destroyed in war except
america i mean we fought the war abroad
but we weren't destroyed
at home our productive capacity was
intact and on top of that we had the
bretton woods agreement so there was
some limit to the amount of money that
the the government could print after
1971 when richard nixon uh richard nixon
took us off the gold standard then it
really became a free-for-all where we
could just print as much money as we
want and a lot of times left-wing people
will point back to the early 70s as this
time where even bernie sanders i think
point points to this sometimes or he
goes you know since the 70s wages
haven't kept up with productivity and
all of a sudden the real super rich are
getting really really rich and the
working class doesn't have the same rise
in standard of living and this is what
it all comes back to is that if you have
a government that can print money out of
thin air with absolutely nothing to to
restrain it you're going to get an awful
crony fascistic economy it's really
simple man you are sitting there holding
a big beautiful cheeseburger that you
cooked for yourself and i walk up and i
have a rock in my hand and i say trust
me this rock is valuable i'll give you
this rock for your cheeseburger and
they're like deal and then you're then
you take that cheeseburger you gave them
nothing for it but they think it's
valuable
or
it's just slowly eroding the value away
so the government can come in do no real
work
buy things convince people to do things
services labor resources and they're not
putting anything into this right well
listen this is what ron paul used to
always say which i think is like the
best way to look at it right is that all
the government can do is tax now there's
three forms of how they can tax you they
can just tax you in which case you pay
your taxes or they can borrow money
which is basically just a promise that
they'll tax you in the future or they
can print money which is in effect a tax
because it robs the value of your money
it's all says those things dave he still
says this he's not dead yet that's a
good point he's still he says them more
than ever but what i mean is that when
he was when he was running for president
he used to make these points you're
right the great ron paul still says
these things but the point is that the
government if you just think about it
like this and the terms you were laying
out right all that is happening is
there's production that's how wealth is
created as things
people produce things they work the
government doesn't produce anything all
they do is take from us bureaucracy
they're really good at making
bureaucracy yes but bureaucracy does not
produce anything yeah we have to pay for
the bureaucracy
now hold on there a minute uh dave
couldn't uh an average working joe like
myself just learn these rules and
exploit this system to benefit in much
the same way the wealthy do well how
would you do that well so you understand
how they they they deflate these
currencies and things right or i'm sorry
they inflate the currencies they devalue
the currencies so if you take out a
really massive loan
and put your money into a hard asset
that will appreciate say property then
when the dollar continues to become
worthless the debt you owe to the bank
is substantially worth less as well so
the rich people who are holding debt in
dollars
the value of that debt is diminished but
the hard asset stays the same i feel
like you're just telling me your life
story but yes you're ready
look if you can get access to a loan
then yeah certainly there are things
that you can invest in that could
perhaps be a hedge against inflation or
there's a you could invest in precious
metals or in cryptocurrency or something
like that but regardless of that the
vast majority of people probably are not
going to invest in those that's the
point they're out there working and
basically supporting if you wonder you
know there's it's funny because
sometimes uh people like bernie sanders
is just the example it keeps popping in
my head but he'll say these things like
he'll be like did you know that you know
the the of the new money created you
know whatever the numbers are 90 has
gone to the top one percent or something
like this and he's right like his
numbers are right but you look at what
we've had since obama say really since
2008 to now we've had record high
government spending more higher
government spending than any government
in the history of the world and interest
rates have basically remained around
zero the whole time and that's what's
leading to all of this but but isn't it
true that by creating this system uh
wealthy individuals or people of even
modest wealth are able to hedge their
money retain value devalue their loans
and thus it keeps the rabble out of
politics you know we can't have poors
running around actually dictating how we
do things in this country could you
imagine what what are you watching the
patriot recently i'm joking by the way
but you watched the patriot recently and
you have i think it was cornwallis and
he was like you must stop targeting our
officers could you imagine what war
would be like without gentlemen
like that's kind of that's that's i feel
like that's kind of the attitude because
what we're seeing with this kind of
policies
like so joe biden actually is saying
right now
after all this comes out he's like
no i think we should print more money
you know why
rich people they their their their their
assets are in
you know their their their value their
their money is not in dollars
so when one dollar tomorrow is not only
worth the equivalent of 50 cents well
they're holding gold or they're holding
bitcoin or they're holding property in
real estate
the loans to the bank go down for all
the rich people and the poor people but
the poor people also don't have any
money to begin with
so if you're of modest means and you've
got you know a thousand bucks in the
bank tomorrow you got 500 worth in the
bank your loans may be only worth half
as much but you still don't have any
money or any appreciating assets so the
things you do own
you're you're not really gaining all
that much your job isn't now paying you
more money all of a sudden so they're
they're printing out unemployment at 16
bucks an hour so nobody is producing
anything but they're still demanding
things
they are rapidly
deflating the economy which i'm sorry
devaluing yeah i keep mixing it up and
so what's gonna happen is the rich are
going to get richer at rocket speed and
the poor are going to get poorer at
rocket speed that's it's right there we
saw last year with amazon i don't know
what their actual value is but it was
off the charts unexpected i mean
if you'd really thought about it you
would have seen it coming but look at
this we here at tim cast irl are
relegated to drinking rc cola one of the
economies i'm just kidding
tim's been very excited to shout out
i'm like i make sure that we don't get
that garbage in this house that was
actually an upgrade for uh for tim cast
was we were finally you're making enough
money you can pull off the rc cold
that's actually true yeah because most
people would just go to the store and
get what they can yeah and it's going to
be covered at this point you got to work
specifically order the rc man well look
i mean what what drives me crazy about
it is every single time when these
politicians joe biden does it all the
time when he says well you know uh it's
the pandemic that destroyed all of these
jobs i mean let's get real it's not the
pandemic it's not the virus that
destroyed the economy it was government
lockdowns well no it's not even china
and it was the chinese government by the
way who allowed the pandemic to get out
right like there were chinese doctors
who blew the whistle on this whole thing
and they're somewhere in a chinese
prison right now if they're still alive
but it was our own government even
forget what china did it was our own
government that locked down our economy
and destroyed it they're still
locking down the economy in most these
blue states and they're still destroying
the economy even when there is no
even plausibly uh reasonable scientific
argument to do so i mean like you you
look at florida and texas and the fact
that they're open back up and that
they're doing better than the national
average despite what fauci predicted
would happen when florida and texas
opened up and the fact is that we're
basically at a point now with covid
where even though i mean look this was
obvious from about april 2020 but right
now about 50 percent of the adult
population has been vaccinated of the
other 50 who hasn't been vaccinated i
i've seen estimates from 30 to 60
percent have had covet at some point and
have some natural immunity to it on top
of that we basically know now that
asymptomatic spread is
very very low if it happens at all so
the idea of these super spreader events
are pretty much over like that that's
just another that matters because the tv
doctor said so well that's right dr phil
uh epidemiology department says that uh
we have to keep locking down but so all
of this is now
self-imposed or government-improved it
was almost it was always though yeah but
we're we're we're almost beyond this
because now if you look to taxes in
florida that are doing really well they
are still going to be harmed by the
current economic policies of we're going
to give everybody 16 an hour equivalent
unemployment and so that means people in
texas are going to be like why do i why
should i work yeah the response to this
has been absolutely insane it makes me
exactly what you're describing this now
makes me think sometimes when people get
severely ill or something like with
cancer and then they take some sort of
radiation therapy like chemo and the
chemo ends up doing more damage to their
body and and destroying their body and
they die right but they're not always
sometimes if something like that were to
happen they would call it a cancer death
even though the medication was so toxic
that maybe it was a medic the medication
killed the person i i always measured it
as a cancer death for the most part i
feel like the response to the covet
thing
has done more damage than covet did
there's only seems like listen i don't
like that argument because there's only
so much we can do as human beings trying
to trust the experts
the issue now is that you have texas in
florida doing really really well so it's
not this argument about cancer and chemo
and you know oh the doctor said this no
it's like literally texas and florida
have opened up many other states haven't
even shut down i think south and north
dakota's economies have actually grown a
little bit relative to and and they're
seeing similar covert rates so now it's
it's about time to maybe
get back to business and maybe have some
some protection for the the weak the
vulnerable you know the people with the
immunocompromised and we had done that a
long time ago
but we're not even it's not even
necessarily about the pandemic at this
point the issue is
we're supposed to be getting back to
work they've administrated how many
vaccines like 100 million or something
and they're still
the problem is
in march we saw this massive job growth
and joe biden was clapping for himself
and patting himself on the back
and now they're still saying they're
going to ramp up unemployment why
i thought like so west virginia just
announced the mass mandate's going away
that's it they're done with it texas and
florida reopened up
people starting to reopen
so now we're in an economic economic
policy issue that has nothing to do with
the pandemic at this point now they're
literally just giving people money
that's going to stop them from working
and it's funny because this is exactly
what they were saying last year when
there's a few republicans i think thomas
massey was one of them they were like we
shouldn't give people more money than
they could make working because then no
one will work and the the response on
the left this is what i got to say man
anybody who comes to you
and says
you just want poor people to suffer tell
them to shut up anybody arguing that
people shouldn't have to work are not
serious people they're just trying to
steal from you that's it it's like
someone in your house and there's dishes
everywhere and you're like look we gotta
do chores no man you're just oppressing
me i shouldn't have to do any chores
like chores are dumb
no sorry man everyone's got to pitch in
to make sure the house is clean and make
sure things are being produced you got a
large faction of leftists who are
screaming i shouldn't have to work we
should not be listening to those people
those are those are kids those are the
children in the house screaming like
what do i have to do the dishes because
we're all working in this house together
to make the house function
the people who don't want to do any work
you know what you end up with you end up
with some some kids like a 30 year old
child living in a basement just like
really hairy and greasy and just not
doing any work and being like shut up
mom i don't want to work
stop stop stop giving these people
things
they're not they're not serious people
well look and and i will say that there
are i'm sure some people and in fact
there definitely are some people in
situations that are really uh awful
situations where it's hard for them to
work where they you know for whatever
reason but the point to me is that
look
economics are realities
and you can't just pretend that they're
not if they don't feel good in the same
sense that uh i'm sure most people on
the left would understand like why is it
that you want to subsidize green energy
and you want to tax
nicotine
right or to cigarettes because you know
if you subsidize something you're going
to get more of it right if you tack
something you're going to get less of it
that's just those are just economic
realities they don't have emotions
that's just the reality of the situation
just like you know in some sense like
the laws of physics this is what you're
going to get so if you subsidize people
not working and then tax people for
working you are going to get less people
working
than you otherwise and more people not
working so we have to be adult enough to
deal with those realities that if you're
going to pay people to not work
regardless of what the situation is
you're going to get a lot of people who
otherwise would work now not work thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time